und zugeschaltet aus Dresden ist mir
jetzt Sachsens Ministerpräsident Michael
Kretschmer von der CDU einen schönen
guten Morgen guten Morgen Herr
Kretschmer sie fordern wie im übrigen
viele andere auch und zwar schon seit
langer Zeit eine neue Asylpolitik und
sie schließen dafür auch eine Änderung
des Grundgesetzes nicht aus in Artikel
16A unter 1 steht politisch Verfolgte
genießen Asylrecht welche Änderungen
können sie sich da vorstellen
ja über Jahrzehnte war genau das der
einzige Punkt in diesem Artikel 16A und
dann geht der ganze Artikel weiter und
hat dafür gesorgt dass in den 90er
Jahren die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
eine wesentlich höhere Handlungsmacht
hatte tatsächlich auch Schengen
durchsetzen konnte und deswegen wenn man
ihren Beitrag den ich gerade gesehen
habe und der ja ich wie ich finde eine
richtige korrekte
Sachverhaltsaufklärung ist über die
Situation in Deutschland wir wollen
solidarisch sein aber wir kommen an die
Grenzen dessen was möglich ist dann muss
man sich als Deutschland Handlungsmacht
organisieren und wenn dazu eine
Gesetzesänderung notwendig ist muss man
das auch tun denn wir haben kein erkennt
das Problem sondern Wärme
Umsetzungsproblem in den Jahren 2015 und
folgende entschuldigen Sie wenn sich
wenn ich sie da unter nur meine Frage
war ja welche Änderungen konkret Sie
sich vorstellen könnten das interessiert
natürlich auch viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger was sie damit meint naja es geht
um die Realität dass wir unsere Grenzen
nicht ausreichend schützen können dass
wir nicht in andere Schengen Staaten
zurück überführen können dass es uns
nicht gelingt Menschen die hier in
Deutschland sind und nach
rechtsstaatlichem Verfahren kein
Anspruch Asyl haben zurück in ihre
Heimatländer zu bringen es geht um die
Frage dass wir innerhalb der
Europäischen Union sehr unterschiedliche
Sozialleistungen Zahlen Deutschland ganz
oben ist und jetzt würde ich sagen in
aller Ruhe weil das so ein politisches
vermietes Gelände ist und auch
Extremisten ja versuchen damit immer
wieder auch zu punkten das aus der Mitte
der Gesellschaft Bund und Länder
gemeinsam sich auf den Weg machen man
soll eine Grundgesetzänderung nicht
ausschließen man hat es in den 90er
Jahren gesehen das hat geholfen und es
ist kann sein dass man an der ein oder
anderen Stelle nacharbeiten muss klar
ist Deutschland wird auch in Zukunft ein
Land sein was Menschen mit asylanspruch
auch helfen wird
vielleicht auch so Einordnung für die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer dass man
mal ein Gefühl für die Dimension auch
bekommt die Zahlen des BMI von Ende 2022
da zu nennen 1,5 Millionen
schutzbedürftige leben bei uns davon
sind lediglich 44.000 überhaupt nach
Artikel 16A des Grundgesetzes
asylberechtigt 760.000 dagegen sind über
die Genfer Flüchtlingskonvention
gekommen also würde eine Änderung des
Grundgesetzes wirklich Entlastung
bringen naja es geht ja auch um die
Frage welche pulfaktoren wir haben warum
kommen die Menschen alle zu uns und
warum fällt es uns so schwer sie wieder
zurück in die Heimatländer zu bringen
und dann kann es schon sein dass man an
der einen oder anderen Stelle
nacharbeiten muss beispielsweise bei der
Frage die das Bundesverfassungsgericht
ja auch jetzt geklärt hat wieder im
Gerichtsurteilen welche Leistungen
finanzielle Leistungen muss man bezahlen
was ist die Existenzgrundlage und ist es
wirklich so dass Personen die aus
wirklich anderen Weltregionen zu uns
kommen Asyl beantragen und dann von
einem
unterschiedlichen Verfahren also
rechtschreiblichen Verfahren
dokumentiert bekommen nein sie haben
keinen Anspruch auf Asyl dass man die
tatsächlich so behandeln muss wie wir
das derzeit tun und das sind alles Dinge
die würde ich sagen nicht von jetzt auf
gleich in dieser Minute zu beantworten
sind aber wir müssen die Offenheit haben
wir müssen so wie sie das in ihrem
Beitrag gesagt haben klären dass die
Zahlen am Ende des Jahres nicht bei 4
oder 500.000 sind weil wir ja auch
andere Aufgaben noch haben wir wollen
ein migrationsgesetz haben die Menschen
die zu uns kommen die hier arbeiten
sollen mit ihren Familien die werden
auch Unterstützung brauchen und deswegen
braucht es einen vernünftiges
ausserieren Einsatz noch wir haben in
den Jahren 2015 folgende miteinander
einen Konsens erzielt denke ich in
Deutschland dass die Grenze irgendwo bei
200.000 Personen ist die wir hier gut
integrieren können wir sind auf dem Weg
in Richtung vier bis 500.000 also müssen
wir handeln schon mal gehört das auch
die illegale Migration einzudämmen
Stichwort Sicherung oder Kontrolle der
EU Außengrenzen nennt sie Faser sagt sie
strebt das mit der Ampel kann im Übrigen
wenn man sich EU-weit bis 2024 auf ein
neues Asylsystem einigen ja wie stellen
Sie sich das vor wie soll das aussehen
pro asylbefürchtet de facto haftlage an
den EU-Außengrenzen es geht und es um
das nochmal zu dokumentieren es geht
immer um diese nicht gesteuerte illegale
Migration dass wir ein Land sind was
Zuwanderungsland ist dass wir wirklich
Fachkräfte von außen brauchen dass wir
offen sein müssen dass wir eine
Veränderung des migrationsgesetz
brauchen alles richtig es geht um diese
ungesteuerte Migration und da gibt es
verschiedenste Instrumente klar ist wenn
die EU Außengrenze nicht gesichert ist
wenn wir nicht kontrollieren können wer
kommt nach Europa dann müssen wir über
die Binnengrenzen sprechen das ist ja
das Thema mit Polen und das ist sehr
unangenehm für uns auch in der
Europäischen Union deswegen finde ich
richtig wenn es uns gelingt diese
Verfahren an der EU Außengrenze zu
organisieren zur Wahrheit gehört
deutschland ist das Land was bisher in
der Europäischen Union immer gebremst
hat jetzt gibt's da eine Veränderung
hoffentlich ist das auch alles zu ernst
erscheint als wir darüber diskutiert
haben das Zäune gebaut werden das
wirklich Grenzkontrollen beispielsweise
Bulgarien Türkei stattfinden dann waren
es die deutschen Politiker der linken
Parteien die uns dafür sehr beschimpft
haben auch ganz kurz wenn man die Dinge
so weiter laufen lasse befürchten sie
dass das nicht gut ausgehe ist ihr Zitat
was befürchten sie da konkret sie haben
das alles in ihrem Beitrag wunderbar
dargestellt die Bürgermeister die
Landräte gemeinsam mit uns als
Ministerpräsidenten sind seit einem
halben Dreivierteljahr dabei in
wirklichen großer Ruhe aber mit sehr
große Ernsthaftigkeit der
Bundesregierung die Situation zu
erklären wir haben keine Wohnungen wir
haben keine integrations- und
Deutschkursen ausreichendem Maße in den
Schulen funktioniert diese Integration
nicht und das ist doch nicht in Ordnung
ist doch nicht unser Anspruch und es ist
auch am Ende eine Sache die so nicht
funktionieren kann und deswegen wir
haben eine Größenordnung uns mal gegeben
von 200.000 Personen sie haben Ihren
Beitrag gerade die Zahlen vom
vergangenen Jahr genannt wir sind auf
dem Weg Richtung 400 bis 500.000
Deutschland muss handeln wir sind
hilfsbereit als Länder und Kommunen aber
der Bund muss bereit sein mit uns diese
Dinge auch wirklich verändern zu wollen
Michael Kretschmer war das der
Ministerpräsident aus Sachsen vielen
Dank für das Interview bitte